while Chris Martin was performing in
Central Park his ex winix outro was less
than a hundred miles away in the
Hamptons she was saying I do in front of
her celebrity friends to gorgeous gold
wedding bands sealed the deal for the
new mr. and mrs. voucher about 70 guests
attended the intimate nuptials
there was a superstar guest list Robert
Downey jr. was behind the wheel as he
and wife Susan attended their passengers
Rob Lowe and his wife Cheryl just two
weeks ago Robert and the bride were on
the set of the Avengers infinity war
sequel Cameron Diaz and husband Benji
Madden were there along with Steven
Spielberg and wife Kate Capshaw
Spielberg is Gwyneth's Godfather
back in January Gwyneth told me she was
a no-frills bride I'm old to have a big
wedding and a big old white dress and
all that the groom who is the co-creator
of American Horror Story arrived in a
red Jeep Jerry Seinfeld and wife Jessica
held the wedding rehearsal dinner Friday
night at their massive Hamptons mansion
the bride wore a custom-designed wedding
gown and at the reception she danced
through the night the fowl shows are now
a blended family Gwyneth is the new
stepmom to brad son and daughter earlier
this year the bride told Good Morning
America her own two kids Apple and Moses
were pumped for their mom to tie the
knot the kids are they excited for the
wedding and they are excited and this is
the first actual wedding yes yes Chris
and I eloped and so I've never had a
wedding or any of these fun like bride
kind of things so I'm really enjoy
myself Oh spread and live on a Monday
I'm totally happy for them the best you
know go Gwyneth get married
[Music]
[Applause]